a simple question  what is it right now  that knows my voice  what is it that knows the helicopter  that just passed  overhead  why do we so habitually  overlook the power to know  and might the power to know  that we perpetually overlook  might consciousness itself  be god might  the universe itself be  our creation and we  watch it from right here  the power to know that we so habitually  overlook and we might ask  how do i stop habitually overlooking  consciousness how do i relax more and  more  into the fact that i am god how do i  relax  into just pure  being pure awareness itself  the answer my friends is up to you it's  your  direct unique experience  but the most simple the most easy way  is to just relax  just breathe and become aware  that you exist